so before we get too far into this video
I do want to say that there may be
spoilers involving the upcoming film
guardians of the galaxy and the
character Roman day played by john c
reilly
and the character Nova prime being
portrayed by Glenn Close what I also
want to let you guys know is that I've
split this video into two categories the
first is a discussion on Richard Rider
and the second is a discussion on the
Nova Corps
so Richard Reiter is introduced to us in
Nova issue number one that came out in
September of 1976 and he is the creation
of Marv Wolfman and John Mishima and
right off the bat almost as soon as
we're introduced to the character of
Richard Reiter we can almost immediately
draw a parallel with him and Peter
Parker and this is actually not a
coincidence Marv Wolfman wanted Richard
Rider to be an amalgamation of both
Peter Parker and Hal Jordan the Green
Lantern from DC Comics and we see the
influence of both characters in terms of
Richard Rider as Nova and Richard Rider
assembly just himself in the early days
of his comic book run along the same
time that were introduced to Richard
rider we also see a being heading
towards the planet Earth in pursuit of a
villain names or and we know this
individual is dying but we also know
that Zoar had destroyed this
individual's homeworld but this
individual by virtue of the fact that he
is dying is unable to face or in
one-on-one combat and so he's looking
for someone that he can channel his
powers into that can take up his cause
and defeat the villains or now this is
the difference between the Green Lantern
Hal Jordan and Richard Reiter as nova in
DC comics when the Green Lantern gains
his abilities when Hal Jordan is
bestowed with the powers of the Lantern
Corps we see that the ring chooses him
because he is the best person suited for
the role of the Green Lantern with
Richard Rider it's not that way
Richard Rider is bestowed with these
abilities at random there's no selection
process he's not examined or inspected
or anything along those lines they're
simply just bestowed on him in the hopes
that he will use these powers for good
instead of using these powers for evil
and we see that gamble pay off we see
that after a brief conversation between
this being and Richard Reiter that
Richard Reiter undertakes the mantle of
Nova and Nova prime and begins a
campaign as a street-level crime fighter
but over the course of the first issue
he rises through the range pretty fast
that is to say he goes from fighting
street-level villains to findings or but
halfway through the fight with zoar
soros teleported away now we don't
really know what happens to him until
the epilogue of issue number one and we
learned that it was the being that
granted Richard Reiter his powers the
teleported Zora way this being and Zoar
engaged in some kind of combat although
we don't know exactly how long it is and
we know that Zora is defeated however
the being dies as well now from this
point forward we don't really know who
this being was we don't know how it was
that he gained his powers or absolutely
how he gave these powers to Richard
Rider or even where his powers came from
until issue number 8 and an issue number
8 we see that Richard Rider comes in a
contact with the spaceship that this
being had previously arrived on and the
spaceship it's revealed is actually just
one part of a colossal kind of organic
computer system that hails from the
planets and our which is where this
being also called Roman day came from
and we learned that this this organic
computer is referred to as the Zen
Dorian world mind and this is
information that we pick up and the
Fantastic Four issues number 206 to 214
we learn that this end
in world mind is a intelligent evolving
artificial intelligence that houses all
of the experience and knowledge of every
previous ends and Arion that has ever
existed in addition to every member of
the Nova Corps that has ever existed now
what we also see is that towards the end
of the comics in addition to richard
ryder undertaking the challenge of
facing foes like diamond head and
addition to the sphinx one of his most
enduring foes he also elevates from the
realm of a earthbound superhero to a
galactic superhero by issue number 19 or
20 I think we see that he is involved in
a campaign to keep these Scrolls from
destroying what's left of the planets
and our and this is when we actually see
what Xander is left at we see that
Xander has not been entirely destroyed
but is actually four domes that are
interconnected using technological means
but we see that the scrolls are
attempting to invade and destroy it now
of course with the assistance of the
Fantastic Four
Richard Reiter as Nova is able to propel
the forces away and is able to saves and
art however in Rama's space Knight
issued number 24 the storyline comes to
an end and we see that Richard Ryder is
looking to return home however he cannot
do so with his powers intact and so at
this point is perceived that his powers
are stripped away from him and then he
has sent back home this brings an end to
the publication the 25 issue run of Nova
vol 1 and we won't see or hear from him
again until 1989
now Nova returns in the mighty thor
issue numbers 411 and 412 alongside a
new group of superheroes dubbed the new
warriors and in July of 1990 running
until September of 1996 for about 75
issues the new warriors have their own
storyline and in addition to this in
January of 1994 running until about June
of 1995 we see the Nova returns in his
own solo series now from this point
going forward this is the pattern that
we will see with regards to Richard
Ryder and Marvel Comics he will be a
part of the new warriors in volume 2 and
volume 3 annual
also have his own solo storyline
continued in volumes 3 and volume 4 and
what we see is that Richard Rider is
expanded as a comic-book character not
just only in a sense of his abilities
which expand several times over in the
events after the annihilation storyline
but we also see him expand as a person
we see him expand as an individual
ultimately we see that the character
Nova comes to a head he eventually dies
in a storyline called the Thanos
imperative or the very least is
perceived that he dies and the Thanos
imperative was a storyline whereby after
the events of the annihilation conquest
storyline a fault a rift was open in
space that was able to transfer anyone
or anything to an alternate universe
called the cancerverse eventually the
cancerverse fills into our universe and
we come into contact with a evil being
named Lord Marvell who is that
universe's version of our Captain Marvel
we see that ultimately the storyline
comes to an end when Nova along with
star-lord are able to keep Thanos at bay
and the cancerverse after Lord Marvel
has been destroyed by Thanos and the
entity death ultimately the rift seals
and star-lord and Nova are considered to
have been killed in the process as the
cancerverse
imploded in on itself due to the chain
reaction of Lord Marvel having been
killed now I know it's a little
confusing and it seems a little I guess
obscure with regards to the Thanos
imperative storyline but we will do a
video about that in the future so that
all this can tie in and that it can make
sense but with Nova as a character we
see him evolve we see him grow and
that's really kind of the reason for the
popularity of his character initially he
starts out as an unsuspecting kid you
know given these powers that he doesn't
know how to wheel that he doesn't know
how to use and over the course of a
multitude of comic books over a
multitude of volumes that span the
course of almost 40 years we see that he
grows from this uncertain kid who
doesn't have much confidence in himself
to a galactic Spanish superhero that
fights from the most formidable enemies
that have ever been seen in Marvel
Comics
so the nova corps are a really
interesting group in the realm of Marvel
Comics and in the prologue to the
annihilation storyline we learn that the
original group of the Nova Corps their
founding purpose was to protect their
home planets and are in addition to
protecting the Zend Orion world mind and
this was done at all costs even if it
meant the life of a member of the Nova
Corps now we see in Volume one of Nova
that the Nova Corps engages in a
conflict with these Scrolls now the Nova
Corps is not entirely obliterated here
although the ranks are pushed to almost
total non-existence we see the once
Richard Ryder leaves that the Nova Corps
is kind of in a state of reformation
that is to say that it's trying to
rebuild itself but then we see in volume
2 of Nova that the Nova Corps is almost
entirely wiped out again at the hands of
nebula in addition to the destruction of
their homeworld Xander now we see in
volume 4 I believe during the
annihilation storyline that the Nova
Corps itself is wiped out entirely there
was no one left with the exception of
Richard Ryder himself and we also
learned that these n Darion hive mind
which at this point in the annihilation
storyline and after the annihilation
storyline has bonded itself to to
Richard Ryder enlists ego the Living
Planet as a news and are a base of
operations
now Richard Ryder is opposed to this and
because he's opposed to this any speaks
openly against it he stripped of his
powers and his rank and is kicked out of
the Nova Corps now eventually he is
brought back into the Nova Corps due to
a dire set of circumstances and the Nova
Corps is reformed again which includes
individuals such as his brother Robert
Rider now the weight of the Nova Corps
is set up is really kind of intriguing
in and of itself the Nova Corps consists
of four categories of people with the
highest category being one individual
the very base level of the Nova Corps
are called corpsman and these are
individuals who have just graduated from
the Nova Corps training school or
training can although we see of course
after the annihilation storyline when
the Nova Corps is reformed first
traditional store or no traditional
training camp per se they're just made
into members of the Nova Corps after
that our Millennials and Millennials
have the ability to wield about 50% of
the Nova Force power we're corpsman only
have the ability to will about 25% now
these individual individuals cannot fly
but they are very very good in terms of
piloting vehicles they simply just don't
possess the ability to fly on their own
now after millenniums Arden Ariens and
Numair Ian's are kind of the middle tier
when it comes to the Nova Corps they are
right there in the middle in terms of
their comparison to the Nova Prime and
the corpsman they can wield about 75% of
the Nova force and they can also fly now
with Centurions
Centurions are the absolute upper
echelon of the Nova Corps with the
exception of Nova prime him or herself
the Centurions have the ability to wield
I think somewhere around somewhere
between 75 or I guess maybe 76 percent
to a hundred percent of the Nova force
although they can't use it to its
fullest extent these individuals are the
individuals where the Nova prime is
selected from and the Nova prime is the
highest ranking member of the Nova force
they are endowed with 100% of the Nova
force's power they can use the Nova
force for virtually anything that the
Nova force is capable of achieving and
this is the role that that Richard Ryder
receives as soon as he becomes Nova in
the first issue of Nova the comic book
series now the Nova Corps in and of
themselves again are a group of
individuals who once they had been
destroyed after the first event after
the invasion of these Scrolls began to
look towards the idea of being a
galactic protector as opposed to simply
being a group of individuals that
guarded their home planet and so this is
when we see the Nova Corps stretching
out this is when we see the Nova Corps
expanding into other parts of the galaxy
and becoming a galactic protection
protection group and this is where you
see people begin to compare the Nova
Corps to the Green Lantern Corps and DC
Comics although each of them have their
own individual quirks that make them
separate but suffice it to say the Nova
Corps is the premier group of fighters
from the planet
xander and is actually one of the
premier group of fighters in the Marvel
Comics universe as a whole
so Richard Reiter as Nova derives his
abilities from something called the Nova
force and the Nova force is actually
really really intriguing here in fact I
don't really think there are many things
like it in the realm of Marvel Comics in
terms of how its implemented and how it
is dispersed among members of the Nova
Corps
the Nova force is pure energy and it's
really really similar to the power
cosmic I would say in a lot of different
ways but an individual who's able to tap
into the full brunt of the Nova force
can channel those energies for virtually
unlimited effects but most commonly as
we see Richard Reiter using them they're
used for things like opening stargates
traveling from one side of the universe
to the other using vast energy
manipulation abilities to create
disruptions and electromagnetic
atmospheres all different kinds of
interesting things but when it comes to
the dispersion of the Nova force it's
interesting the way that it's done with
the Nova Corps you have the very lowest
level and that's a corpsman that's a
person who has just graduated from the
Academy and they really don't have the
ability to utilize as much of the Nova
force as anybody else I think they can
utilize about 1/4 of the power that the
Nova force represents after that you
have millenniums and millenniums are
able to use about 50% from there you
have denarian so you can use 75% and
then you have Centurions who can use
somewhere between 75% and a hundred
percent although I would argue that it's
probably somewhere right in between
above them and the highest ranking order
of the Nova Corps that is to say the
highest ranking individual is the Nova
prime and the Nova prime is the
individual that has the power to wield
all facets of the Nova force there's no
limit to what it is they can do as long
as it doesn't exceed the power of the
Nova force or what the Nova force is
capable of this is the level that Reed
that Richard Reiter achieves this is the
highest level that he is able to attain
and in fact once he actually bonds with
the Sam Dorian
world mind after the events of the
annihilation storyline he is the Nova
prime and so there really is no limit to
what he can do with the Nova force and
we see him achieve a wide array of
effects we don't really see anything on
the order of reality manipulation or
anything of that sort we really just
kind of see him using the Nova force for
either concussive or destructive blast
or to create wormholes to travel from
one side of the galaxy to the other
because his role is really more of a
defensive role its offensive in the
instance of fighting forces let's say
for example when he goes against the
Phalanx when the Phalanx invade the Kree
Empire but for the most part he's
usually always defending one group of
people against some kind of invading
force and so for this reason we don't
see him tap into the full potential of
what it is that the Nova force is
capable of and I don't think there's
anyone who's ever been able to
demonstrate anything beyond what it was
that that Richard Ryder was able to do
with the Nova force itself so I'm
curious to see how the Nova Corps is
going to be depicted in the guardians of
the galaxy film and there's really only
a couple characters and I'm curious
about the first of course is Roman day
which is being played by john c reilly
and as we've talked about Roman day was
the character that the the Nova Corps
Centurion that gave Richard Rider his
powers in the first place and so I know
that Richard Rider is not going to be in
the guardians of the galaxy film but I'm
wondering if in like a post credit scene
or something like that we might see john
c reilly drifting off towards the planet
earth or something along those lines or
maybe even arriving at planet earth and
then the screen cutting to black which
would of course tell us that Richard
Rider is about to gain his abilities
this is really something we don't know I
mean we know for a fact that given the
fact that the Roman day is alive and
well in this film this takes place
before Richard rider ever gains his
abilities and so we don't know exactly
how his character is going to play out
in addition we don't know a whole lot
about the character just from the
trailers with regards to Glenn Close
playing Nova prime rail then this is
what I'm really interested about because
Glenn Close is an older woman and of
course with her being her age you
probably wouldn't see her in a lot of
combat scenes I
they couldn't imagine Glenn Close
wielding a sword or you know wielding
some kind of crazy you know noble force
powers and destroying people so I'm
really curious to see if she's going to
play more of a diplomatic role or more
of like a spiritual leader and if she
will essentially take on the role of the
Nova prime in addition to kind of being
the marvel cinematic universes version
of these n Dorian world mine I'm not
really sure how that's going to play out
it would make sense that she would play
the world mind in addition to the Nova
prime because in the comics the world
mind is like the spiritual leader in
addition to the overall kind of ruling
member of the Nova Corps and of the
planets and our so it'd be interesting
to see how this kind of thing plays out
I will say that if she is the Nova prime
and she's not actually fighting it seems
like kind of a waste because in every
virtually every version of the Nova
prime that we have seen we've always
seen them take up arms and they're
always the first ones on the line when
it comes to fighting a foe that requires
their attention so I don't know how this
is going to play out but I think it will
be interesting with that being said I'm
going to bring this video to an end and
don't forget to offer your questions and
your suggestions for next week's Marvel
requests Monday I will catch you guys
later
with all these cultures represented then
you kind of have a feeling of with jazz